demain sera en effet un jour sans pain
pour les parisiens les représentants du
syndicat patronat de la boulangerie ont
décidé une fermeture collective des
magasins de la capitale
à partir d'aujourd'hui 14 heures jusqu'à
mardi matin
il semble exclu que la fermeture
s'étendent pour le moment à la province
pourquoi votre boulangerie ce rappel
fermés lundi pour le manifesto et nous
revendiquons une autre rotation du pré
du pape pour nous et pour nos ouvriers
est ce que vous ferez départ lundi matin
non non la nuit ne tombait pas pourquoi
vous ne travaillez pas on fait la grève
pour obtenir une augmentation de salaire
combien gagnez-vous pour l'instant
actuellement 540 de leur nom il faut
faire beaucoup d'heures pour obtenir un
bon solaire vous voulez une augmentation
du pain parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont augmenté depuis deux ans
oui on va bien sûr d'abord premièrement
il faut remonter aux ouvriers ensuite
nos loyers qui augmentent les pattes en
qui on augmente les charges sociales
ensuite comment les impôts et surtout
également ce qu'on n'oublie pas ce qu'on
oublie son entretien de notre matériel
auprès du pain n'a pas augmenté depuis
cela faire deux en deux ans qu'il n'a
pas bougé depuis le mois de juillet 68
je crois le gouvernement est contre
cette augmentation
le gouvernement n'est pas spécialement
content mais enfin il retarde toujours
l'échéance de l'augmentation et nous
aurions voulu qu'il soit fait pour le
pour le 1er avril
moment a remis ça à nos prochaines
récoltes cheria dieu